peter how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself i am
doing fantastic i'm super excited to
talk to you when i told people that you
were coming on i got inundated with
questions
and uh and all kinds of things to talk
about so maybe first let's just start
with the russia ukraine conflict i think
is kind of the the event that everyone
is focused on at the moment oh there's a
war i hadn't noticed
when when you think about that what is
your analysis in terms of like how do we
get here and is it specifically related
to just the nato kind of expansion and
what's i think been talked about a lot
in the mainstream media or are there
other elements that led to this event
that maybe people aren't as aware of or
paying attention to
this was always inevitable uh in any
world where the united states
is no longer banning war and is no
longer regulating commerce in the way
that we did during the cold war in the
post-cold war period uh the russians
were always going to go out and try to
resecure what they see as the gateway
invasion access corridors uh places like
the polish plains the best arabian gap
uh the baltic sea they were always going
to try to do this uh what has changed
is that the russians are literally dying
out and the post cold war generation
that was born through the 1990s was so
small that the russians were losing the
capacity to field a regular army so if
they didn't do it now they would lose
the possibility and there they would be
then unanchored in this kind of great
open flat zone in the middle of eurasia
and the next time there's a war they
couldn't stop it so they're hoping to
forward position what they've got left
in these gaps and ukraine unfortunately
is between them and two of the most
important gaps so it's not just that
they're going for ukraine they're going
for modova they're going for parts of
romania and poland and all of estonia
and latvia and lithuania it's just a
question of timing uh but ukraine is
the flavor of the month
uh
i kind of see this war as the last
conflict of the cold war because as long
as the russians existed
and
their security was going to drive their
decision-making so it's kind of like how
the civil war was the final war of the
american revolution we're kind of at the
end of this section of history now
when you think about what's happening uh
kind of on the ground and of course i i
always am careful to say like we don't
really know what's happening because we
can just go off of the reports that
we're getting uh it seems like uh russia
may have thought that they would uh be
able to be successful in ukraine much
quicker than they have been so i think
they've been a little surprised by the
resistance that they faced and also it
appears that uh they may have thought
that china or other countries were going
to have much more support for them than
it appears that they do is that a fair
characterization in terms of maybe some
assumptions that russia had going into
it and they've been surprised by the
lack of success or support that they've
received
absolutely one of the things we've seen
in a lot of the authoritarian
governments that are existence right now
most notably russia and china is that
their leadership has completely isolated
themselves from the rest of the world
and so if you are not
if you are in putin's inner circle you
don't dare give him bad news because he
will kill you so there were a lot of
assumptions that were made in the
kremlin that just have turned out to not
be true now in all due defense to putin
and the kremlin everyone in the west was
thinking the same way
we never thought that the europeans
would pull together in the way that they
did we never thought that we would get
any sort of meaningful international
sanctions that included countries like
japan and korea we thought that the
ukrainians would crumble we thought that
the war would be over in a month you
know everyone has gotten it wrong but
from my point of view the single
biggest flaw
is the complete collapse installation
institutionally of the russian military
they are making mistakes that were worse
than what the iraqis did in 1992 or what
they themselves did during the chechen
wars just that the inability of them to
launch any sort of meaningful
multi-domain operation and what we
thought of as the second most advanced
military in the world is just
blows your mind
and forces the russians now to do siege
mentality tactics where they just
obliterate civilian infrastructure
because now that's the only way they can
win the war
when you start to think about
the participation of nato allies in this
conflict there still is no no-fly zone
there still is uh at least officially no
troops on the ground from those nato
allies uh but there seems to be quite a
bit of flowing of both capital uh and
weaponry to ukrainian forces uh how is
that helping would they not be able to
provide this resistance without that
and i guess kind of how important is it
that the european countries came
together
along with the united states to provide
the support to ukraine
well i don't have a good answer for you
for how the europeans came together
because no one even in europe
anticipated this level of support and
everyone is taking any weapon system
that they can that doesn't require a
static footprint uh like uh so no jets
because that requires an airport uh or
an airfield but anything that can be
carried or moved by truck uh that is not
nailed down is being shipped in
and the reason originally was they
wanted to give the ukrainians a fighting
chance
but i think it was the convoy that was
north of kiev the 40 mile long one that
terrified western leaders
because we hear we have this 40 mile
convoy with thousands of vehicles that
stalled out in a day because of lack of
fuel just horrible logistics and then
two days later they ran out of food and
so all the soldiers had to get out and
walk back to belarus just leaving their
vehicles behind
well you know from a certain point of
view that's a yay the russians are
incompetent but until you realize that
if there ever was a direct conflict
between western and especially american
forces and russian forces on the
battlefield the russians would be
obliterated
that's a bad thing because it means that
if russia pushes through and captures
all of ukraine and moves to its next
stages which are those gaps in romania
and poland for example there will be a
direct flight fight and the russians
would be obliterated
and they would then face a simple choice
do we go into a humiliating strategic
withdrawal from which this country will
never recover or do we up the ante to
include nukes
and so once that
decision once that issue kind of sank in
in the white house in dod now we are
almost desperate to send any possible
weapon systems that we can so in april
this war is going to be incredibly
bloody because when the war started
the ukrainians only had a few hundred
uh javelin anti-tank launchers and they
only had a few dozen stinger
anti-aircraft missiles
well
that was before the americans started
supplying things in bulk they're only
now starting to arrive so we're talking
about the uh the russians suffering tank
and air attrition at an order of
magnitude higher than they are right now
and this is gone from an issue well we
need to slow the russians and extract a
cost but we know we can't win to a
if we don't win we are really risking a
nuclear conflict we have to do
everything we can short of regular
direct intervention to crush the entire
russian system as quickly as possible so
ukraine is now the field upon which this
will all be determined
so it feels like there's two conflicts
that are uh very much tied together the
first is the violent conflict that's
playing out in ukraine this is the
russian forces versus ukrainian forces
uh the ukrainians have the support of
nato the united states uh and many other
allies uh the russians have you know
somewhat of a trump card in that they're
nuclearly armed and no one wants to push
them far enough to actually execute that
power
that's the violent conflict there's also
a financial war that seems to be taking
place which
was essentially over before it even
started once the european countries plus
the united states came together and they
levied what are unprecedented sanctions
against not only uh the russian banks
the central bank uh their leadership but
also what essentially has been every
single wealthy person that even knows a
politician it seems like uh in russia
seems to be getting all of their assets
frozen et cetera like talk a little bit
about what your analysis is of the
financial war that's being levied and
just how effective that has been so far
okay so first the splash that's in the
news second the stuff that's behind it
that's actually more important and then
the third what's coming so
the splashes in the news is going after
the oligarchs in the 1990s a group of
people took advantage of the collapse of
the soviet system and grabbed assets for
themselves by on any number of means
very little of it was what we would
consider elite or what the russian law
would consider illegal because there
wasn't a lot of russian law then but it
was definitely unethical and they have
now become multi-billionaires uh this
first batch of oligarchs when putin came
in in the year 2000 he brought them to
heal
he made them a deal that if they stayed
completely out of politics he would not
go after their assets and so they've
there's been this truce between them for
the last 20 years
under putin he elevated a number of
people from his fsb days kgb days based
on who's doing the math
uh to take over large portions of the
russian economy this includes things
like the defense industry gazprom
and which is the world's largest natural
gas company and rosneft which is the
world's second largest oil company and
these are all people who are not part of
that original group
these are people who are all in putin's
inner circle
so we're going after two different
groups of oligarchs here the ones that
are around putin totally worth it these
are people who have been with putin
bolted to the hip with every single
policy he's done for 20 years these
people should be brought down
the other people the folks that have
been there since the 1990s i don't mean
to suggest that they're kinder gentler
folks i mean they are robber barons at
best but going after them just makes you
feel good because they have very little
influence over putin so we're talking
here about melons scooping the entire
core out of the russian economy by going
after the leadership but
one group is not going to affect the war
whatsoever and that's that first group
in the 90s they're the ones who have
most of their assets overseas so they're
the ones who are actually vulnerable to
what's going on
now behind that
we didn't just sanction a bunch of
companies and people we sanctioned the
russian central bank
and we don't think of how important the
central bank is in systems because we
always assume it's a neutral actor in
the background that maybe messes around
with interest rates and bond purchases
and that's about it but they are the
primary connectivity point between any
economy and the rest of the world one of
the thousands reasons that i'm not a big
fan of bitcoin is it assumes that the
central banks a will empower it and b
will do nothing to impede it and that's
clearly not true and in the case of the
russian central bank they can no longer
deal with any entity in any of these
countries and access any currencies that
are dollars euros yen one australian
dollars canadian dollars taiwanese
dollars and i'm sure i've met swiss
francs i'm sure i've left out a bunch
so
anything that the bank tries to do
anywhere cannot use any of those normal
channels and so among other things that
denied the russians access to some 90 of
their currency reserves that means that
when they sell oil somebody has to like
physically do a transfer in a third
party and fly the money into moscow this
is not a tenable situation we tried
doing some version of this for iran and
it was crushing but we've never done it
to an economy this bigger this
holistically
and then what's coming
we have a number of sanctions against
russia it's the most sanctioned country
in history now actually it has more
sanctions on it than all other countries
and all other time frames throughout
human history
the europeans are now talking about an
open ban
on all sales of russian crude
not
just to the europeans themselves because
all that would do is shift the pain
they're talking at the beginning of the
process of talking about making sure
that russian crew can't make it to
market anymore that would mean among
other things blocking ships from going
in and out of the baltic sea probably
the scagger hat and probably blocking
ships going in and out of the black sea
probably through the turkish straits
now how the russians would respond to
that would be really interesting but if
the blockades are further back from
russian ports the russians militarily
can't do anything about it
so we're looking here at removing four
to five million barrels a day of crude
production from the world that is more
than enough to guarantee an energy
induced depression that is global in
scale and the crazy thing is we might
even get there without an official
sanction because insurance companies are
not allowing ships to go into these
ports the ports are shallow so they
can't take super tankers and then run it
to china so either you get this daisy
chain of dozens of mid-sized vessels
that are going to be loading onto a
super tanker inside of a nato port and
expecting that nato is not going to do
anything about it
or they just close the straight
altogether one way or another we are
headed for a very interesting year
so we'll get to commodities in one
second but i want to talk about this
central bank kind of sanction that you
mentioned sure uh which is uh it's one
thing to say hey you cannot transact
right if i said hey peter central bank
you're not allowed to transact uh in
these certain currencies or in these
other uh uh other organizations there's
an added piece though where we
essentially have frozen or confiscated
the central bank reserves as well and
that to me feels like it is uh today a
footnote given how complex this
situation is and how um kind of uh uh
just mind-boggling everything
but it has massive ramifications across
many countries over the next you know 50
to 100 years what is your thoughts
around the actual freezing and
confiscation of another country central
bank reserves that just happen to not be
within their border
let me put it to you from the point of
view of an outsider so here we've got
the united states who has been moving
down a path towards isolationism for 30
years and it just wakes up one day
decides that it wants to get involved in
the ukrainian russian situation
uh it's been removing troops from the
middle east it's been removing troops
from asia it's been removing troops from
europe
we when biden was elected we were at the
low point for international involvement
uh since
reconstruction we had fewer troops
stationed abroad that since
reconstruction so you know we're at 150
year low right now
and now we're telling people that they
can't use the dollar
or any currency
everyone who thought that the american
retreat was going to give rise to a
multi-polar world in which the united
states had minimal power really hadn't
been paying attention to how the world
works
to have a global currency the first
thing you have to be sure of is that the
country that issues currency has to
really not care about what happens with
it every single day because if they're
going to manipulate the currency in
order to achieve trade advantages then
nobody's going to want it in addition it
has to be you know sufficiently deep
full of liquidity in order to work
there's only one country that fits that
criteria there's only one country that's
fit that criteria since 1945 and it's
certainly not china and people are
discovering now countries are
discovering now
that if you want to be part of that
system
there are certain things you can and
cannot do
invading countries that for whatever
reason the united states should not be
invaded makes the list
and so i would say that the the biggest
panic the biggest damage that we are
seeing from the ukraine war outside of
ukraine obviously is in china because in
one month the russians have pulled back
the blinders on what has been a 50-year
strategic program the idea that china
can have the global power with american
sponsorship with american indifference
that it can take taiwan that it can
intimidate japan that can dominate all
of east asia and yet not suffer
economically at all it was always
ridiculous but now it's been shown to
just be absolutely stupid
now the question moving forward of
course is what's the next thing the
united states is going to care about and
considering how erratic our politics
have been for the last 15 years that's a
tough question but it's something that
every single country that trades now has
to obsess about if they want to continue
doing anything along the lines that they
thought they could
it's basically i have to uh remain in
good standing with the issue of the
global reserve currency or else i could
be next right exactly and there's and
there's nowhere else to go i mean the
yuan is only traded internally because
it's the most manipulated currency in
history
the euro confiscates bank deposits to
pay for bailouts i mean there are there
things that the fed could do better in
my opinion of course
but compared to all the competition i
mean
there isn't any competition so let's
talk about commodity prices uh i
specifically want to start with oil and
natural gas we've talked a ton
on this show about the fact that the
third largest oil producer i think they
come up with almost 15 or so of all
natural gas globally and it's not just
is it produced in
russia or even in the ukraine uh kind of
region but also uh there's a lot of flow
of these assets as you were describing
uh in terms of the straits and many
things that are kind of uh being
at least evaluated as potentially uh
creating problems
how do you think about let's start with
oil maybe first and
the price has exploded it's come back
down there's people running around
saying that if we actually stop buying
oil and natural gas from russia
it'll create these energy shocks like
what's your evaluation of it sure now
i'm not a financial analyst so i'm going
to put that out there at the beginning
as a caveat i am going to throw some
numbers out there where i think this is
going to go based on supply mechanics
but you know take take it with a grain
of salt okay so russia is the world's
second largest oil exporter and it
exports via four main routes one to
china one to the baltic sea one to the
black sea and then on via pipe to europe
what's going on right now because of the
ukrainian war is that the pipes that go
to europe are going to be disrupted
either by the war itself or because
ukrainian partisans are targeting
russian income flows one way or another
those pipes aren't surviving this year
the stuff that goes to the black sea is
in a war zone so insurance companies
will not give the indemnification
that is necessary for vessels to operate
in that area so the only way a ship can
go and dock at novr ceased right now is
if a country gives its sovereign
indemnification and takes all the risk
some of that is happening with the
chinese it might be happening with the
indians that's the little touch you can
go they're still under negotiation
primorse that's the baltic port so right
next to st petersburg that is not in a
war zone so you can get insurance to go
to primorsk however ship captains for
the most part are not uh are refusing to
go and european dock workers are
refusing to unload the cargo when it
arrives so that is still in use but not
nearly as much maybe a quarter of what
it used to be before the war started and
then the final pipes either terminate
on the pacific coast near um
vladivostok or there is a short spur
line that goes down into king and
northeastern china now
the western three
black sea the pipes to europe baltic sea
those are interconnected to a decree so
if there's a problem at one port or in
one pipe they can redirect some less
than a third but some of the crew to
other places it is completely
disconnected from the eastern pipes that
go to china and japan
so if all the stuff in the west is shut
down which is what i think is going to
happen
none of it can go east the rail line is
already operating beyond capacity the
pipelines are already full you would
have to build a fundamentally new
infrastructure from the fields in
northwest siberia to chinese population
centers that is greater than the
distance from miami to anchorage most of
which is through virgin territory that
is very rugged that's a 10-year program
minimum even with the chinese building
it
so
one way or another we are looking at
those western flows which add up to four
to five million barrels a day
going offline
there's still about a million and a half
barrels refined product that might go
out but most of that is going to be via
rail so that'll be a little trickier to
disrupt i figure the europeans can maybe
disrupt half of that if they really want
to
but we're looking at the single largest
removal of crude from the market ever
and in proportional terms it's going to
have a shock somewhat similar to world
war ii
and that assumes that there are no
downstream effects anywhere
because we have insurance companies not
doing it shipping companies not doing it
dock workers not doing it and now
halliburton baker hughes and
schlumberger
have pulled out and they do the
technical work that makes a lot of this
possible all the super majors are gone
we even have a couple of major projects
out on stockland that are probably just
going to die because the russians can't
make those projects work by themselves
most of the oil and gas out of that goes
to china so we're actually looking at an
environment where the chinese see
reduced
flows rather than increased as russia is
just melon scooped out of the market
when you think about this um obviously i
think uh europe the united states many
other
importers of oil and natural gas are
kind of scratching their heads being
like how did we get to this place
um and uh i'll ask this in an open-ended
way because you can take it so many
different directions how did we get to
the place where uh european countries in
the united states are so dependent on
russian oil and natural gas to
essentially survive
i would say there are there are two kind
of main threads here the first one is at
the end of world war ii the americans
changed how the world worked
we created free trade and globalization
and told everyone that it could
participate in any market anywhere
without military escort they could
access our market if in exchange they
formed an alliance with us against the
soviets we bought an alliance and we
guaranteed as part of that alliance
their energy flows so the primary reason
that the u.s has been so bogged down in
the middle east for so long
was because we had to in order to keep
our alliance fueled if the middle east
would have gone offline the european
alliance would have shattered and the
soviets would have walked away with
europe that was the logic
post-cold war
we kept holding up the ceiling we kept
up our end of the deal but there was no
boogeyman so people went their own ways
and in many times that meant that they
started signing deals with the russians
it's gonna thread one thread two
europe's a nasty place its history is
horrific and the world wars were just
the the capstone of what had been a
millennia of conflict and so with the
american-led order the europeans let
themselves believe let themselves hope
that history had finally turned the page
and that they were finally finally had
all that behind them and in that sort of
environment especially in the post-cold
war version of it where the germans had
reunified
russia was seen as a country that in the
end needed to be incorporated into the
european family so that europe could
finally be whole at peace and free
it didn't work
and so we're dealing with a lot of
shattered dreams in europe right now
right alongside with the war because a
lot of people's guiding ideology and
hopes for the future
died on february 22nd when the russians
moved in the tanks
and so one of the reasons i think that
the the european response has been so
vitriolic
is that they're not just disappointed
here they feel betrayed that their whole
idea of what could happen
isn't going to happen anymore and in
their mind it's very clear who's at
fault
when you think about this lack of energy
energy independence both in europe and
in the united states how much of the
environmental kind of pitch over the
last you know 20 years has also played
into it so there's a geopolitical
element which you're you're speaking to
talk a little bit about that in terms of
uh it seems like you know one extreme is
pointing and saying oh the
environmentalists did all of this
another extreme is saying they had
nothing to do with it truth's probably
somewhere in between
yeah the truth is definitely somewhere
in between and if you're looking for
someone to blame i mean if you're if if
that's what you're after here it's
definitely the german greens because
they decided that coal was better for
the environment than
uh nuclear power
they saw it from a nuclear waste point
of view rather than a carbon emission
point of view so there are a number of
countries in europe that followed the
greens and started dismantling the
nuclear power plants which meant that
they had to use something and natural
gas from russia was the cheapest of the
options available that wasn't coal of
course the germans did coal as well
uh so yeah we are looking at an un a
massive unwinding of esg
issues in boardrooms across europe and a
massive unwinding of environmental
progress in general
europe is neither a very sunny nor a
very windy place and so they can build
all the sun the turbines they want and
they put in all the solar panels they
want but in most parts of europe
especially the northern part that is
wealthy
the only way they've been able to bridge
the gap is with russian natural gas and
now that's gone
so they're going to try to build more
solar and wind and they're going to
realize very quickly that that really
isn't going to solve the problem in most
places
they're going to try to bring in lng
from other parts of the world but every
shuttle tanker of lng that they take in
is one that's not going somewhere else
so somebody has to be left-handed
holding the bag it'll probably be the
east asians
and then they're gonna make up the
difference with coal
which the germans have a very big head
start on because they already get about
a quarter of their fuel from something
that's called lignite which is a soft
brown cold it's 20 percent water it is
actually more carbon intensive and less
energy intensity or and generates less
energy than wood
but that's what they have so we're
we're going to see a lot of what we
thought of as progress towards green
goals just
being unwound violently over the course
of the next several months because the
alternative is to have no electricity
and that is not a viable option
let's talk about wheat obviously uh
russia ukraine kind of region is one of
the largest producers of wheat in the
world uh
what is the disruptions that will happen
there and what's the impact uh kind of
globally
well this this is the horrific part if
the energy-induced depression didn't get
you down this well
all right the last time the russians
interfered with exports from the former
soviet union it was 2010
and they had had a bad harvest and a
drought and a lot of fires in western
siberia where they grow a fair amount of
their wheat so they blocked exports for
a couple of months
that drove global wheat prices up by a
factor of two remember food especially
based commodities like wheat have
inelastic demand so it doesn't take much
of a disruption in supply to make prices
go bonkers in their primary export
markets which are the middle east prices
tripled and that triggered the series of
coups and revolts and wars that we now
come to know as the syrian civil war and
the arab spring so
small amount disrupted prices tripled in
the middle east doubled globally big
deal we we're still feeling the effects
of that
oh this is gonna be so much worse so
russia is the world's largest wheat
exporter and most of their wheat is
exported via
novorosis the port that can't be
accessed right now and russia the
world's largest wheat exporter has
invaded ukraine the world's fifth
largest wheat exporter and they are
making a drive for the city of odessa
which is where the iranians offload all
of their wheat so we're looking at two
of the top five maybe not vanishing well
ukraine's vanishing from the market
ukraine's gonna be a net importer this
year they can't plant anymore uh but a
lot of the russian production is not
gonna be able to make it to the global
market only if they can rail it to you
can you still get it so iran's probably
okay
there's going to be a little bit more
maybe going to china
and
that's
everybody everyone else replied upon
russian wheat you're just out of luck
and if you apply it on light on
ukrainian wheat it's just gone and it's
not coming back this decade
that's all piece one that's just piece
one
we had a phosphate and a nitrogen
fertilizer shortage globally when this
all started
you need natural gas to make nitrogen
the european fertilizer manufacturers
have already suspended most of their
nitrogen fertilizer production because
of what's going on the ukraine war and
the cost is already
i believe today we're at sixty dollars
per
thousand cubic feet in uh in europe for
natural gas versus the united states
which is like four and a half
so i mean there's no way you can be
viable making nitrogen at that prices
and that's without sanctions
and forty percent of the world's potash
comes from either russia or belarus so
we now also have a potash shortage
because they can't get that to market so
all three of the primary components that
go into all fertilizers are in shortage
globally
it takes a minimum of three years to
build up the physical infrastructure to
to bring a new phosphate excuse me to
bring out yeah a new phosphate or
nitrogen facility online and probably
closer to 10 years to get the mine and
the mill
situation in place for potash so this
this isn't a one-year issue this is a
multi-year issue
and we're going to have a lot of
countries around the world particularly
on the poorer side that just aren't
going to be able to use fertilizer this
year which means their yields will
create crash
the number one import of russian
fertilizer is brazil that's the world's
second largest agricultural exporter so
at a minimum we're going to see the
prices for their output going up
stratospherically
this is more than enough to trigger a
multi-constant famine that starts
probably in the third or fourth quarter
of this year and then just doesn't let
up for quite some time what does that
mean when you say a multi-continent
famine uh help people understand famine
could mean uh people have a
caloric deficit and aren't getting
enough food it could also mean people
literally get zero food and everyone
dies like like what is the severity or
extreme uh when you describe that well
again let me start with a caveat
uh not that i don't follow this stuff
but there's a lot of other things that
go into agricultural supply chains
assuming that the only disruption we
have to deal with is what's going on in
china with phosphate which is a separate
story and what's going on with potash in
the former soviet union and what's going
on with nitrogen because of natural gas
prices let's assume that there are no
other factors that play into this
we probably only have enough
fertilizer that's going to get out there
to support a population about 6 billion
so that means
we're looking at two billion people
entering chronic
nutrition over the course of the next 18
months
probably uh one of the things we're
going to see is when people realize that
they can't just export widgets or iron
ore and then import wheat because
there's not enough of it they're going
to have to grow it themselves
now luckily
wheat is a weed it is very easy to
cultivate it grows in a wide variety of
climates and under globalization where
everyone goes after whatever bit they
can earn the most money for wheat has
been pushed to the margins
so you can go into a place like
algeria and grow more wheat and rip up
some of your orchards for example
you won't get as much bang for your buck
in terms of income but your people won't
starve that way we're going to see that
happen across africa across latin
america across
east and southeast asia because they're
not going to have much of a choice
so either we have two million people in
malnutrition
or
we have maybe
i'm sorry two billion people or we have
maybe closer to a billion people in
malnutrition and the collapse of the
global agricultural system that brings
us out of season blueberries and
avocados
or somewhere in between
we are definitely entering a period
where it's going to be a very rough
sledding in places like sub-saharan
africa and south asia because they are
the world's most countries that are the
world's sorry they are the parts of the
world that is most dependent either on
direct food imports
or on the imports of the fertilizers
that allow them to grow most of the food
themselves
i would actually toss china into that
bucket as well they're probably at like
an 80 percent import dependency upon the
inputs that allow them to keep the
chinese population alive
uh i've got two of my brothers here joe
and john uh joe what questions do you
have hey peter thanks for joining us uh
off the back of what you just talked
about with the fertilizer shortage in
price increases i think the last time we
saw something similar was around 2008
right where natural gas prices increased
really dramatically and it caused
subsequently the same thing to happen
with fertilizer
i don't know exactly how many people
this calls to be put into chronic
malnutrition but can you compare the two
events right because i think that the
main difference now obviously is we've
had covet for the last two years there's
obviously supply chain issues going
around globally does this make it much
worse or is it just a totally different
event
uh there's definitely some parallels to
draw upon but let me kind of put that in
context so the the primary problem we
had in 2007 to 2008 was that the chinese
boom was huge
it was just gobbling up any resources
they could an american subprime was
generating an artificial inflation of
demand if you will in the united states
at the same time that the iraq war
was keeping oil off the market and
venezuela was early in its national
suicide so we had oil prices between 100
and 150 for a prolonged period of time
that would contribute to the financial
crisis obviously
you don't use oil to make fertilizer
and in a lot of places natural gas is
indexed to oil because a lot of times
they're co-produced but they are
different commodities
so
natural gas was drug up with oil because
of that linkage in 2008 and that
definitely contributed to a fertilizer
problem
but even at its peak in the united
states
uh natural gas never breached seven
now in the united states right now
courtesy of the shale revolution we have
a lot of excess natural gas that we've
been gobbling up in the years since we
went to six at the end of last year
right now we're below five still i don't
think we're gonna go above seven
but in europe
because natural gas
well
natural gas because it's a gas is more
difficult to transport so you need a you
need a more dedicated pipeline system or
you have to bring it in via lng which is
incredibly expensive
before
the war started the europeans were
already experiencing shortage which had
already taken natural gas prices up to
30 compared to six in the united states
it's doubled since then
so we're talking about prices in europe
at least that are seven times what they
were in 2008 at the peak and so it's not
an issue of fertilizer is expensive it's
an issue of they're no longer making it
because the base material is too costly
john what questions do you have yeah
peter thanks for joining us my question
would be about the timing of this
situation so it looks like russia has
been planning this for years why now and
what effect does that have on the
economy globally
well the demographic situation was
certainly pushing some of them to do it
in the in the near term but i asked as
to why specifically why february uh it
had to do with the combination of the
trump impeachment and the biden
administration's changing of arms export
rules so you may remember that uh the
first uh impeachment trial for for
donald trump was about him trying to
blackmail the ukrainian president the
current guy the guy who's like doing
tick tock videos in downtown ukraine
when the bombs are falling that guy
tried to blackmail him into
investigating hunter biden for him in
order to get dirt on the biden family
for his re-election campaign and as a
result of that
he
cut military aid to ukraine
substantially
the russian thinking was if that if
trump wins reelection that's the end of
nato and we'll just be able to swallow
the place well that didn't happen biden
won and one of the first things that
biden did was restart the military aid
and in november
if you remember that's when the russians
started getting all squeaky and screamy
about security issues in europe well
november is when the javelins met the
front line troops in the separatist
provinces of luhansk and donetsk and the
russians actually saw the impact of
american military aid on their troops
that's when the build-up started
peter when you start to think about uh
kind of why they're doing this now i
immediately jump to okay obviously right
now it's not a good situation
there's massive ramifications whether
it's the commodity prices whether it's
kind of second order effects like global
famine uh et cetera
what is the off-ramp how do we get out
of the situation uh if there is any at
all
well
the russians see this as an issue of
existential national survival and i
think they're reading the situation
correctly they they know if they don't
win in ukraine and poland and romania
that this is the end of the end of rush
is inevitable
uh and probably before the mid-century
point they think that if they can plug
those gaps they buy themselves more time
and i think they're reading the
situation correctly
which really does make it a muster down
uh there is not
a version of a piece here that would
satisfy both sides
the russians like to say that you know
if you only gave us what we wanted on
security none of this would have ever
happened but remember what they're
asking for is the ability to
either put troops in or decide the
security policies of finland estonia
latvia lithuania poland of the czech
republic slovakia hungary romania
bulgaria bosnia
croatia slovenia macedonia serbia
ukraine belarus kazakhstan armenia
azerbaijan georgia tajikistan
turkmenistan uzbekistan
i probably missed a couple anyway
they're saying that they need to be able
to write the security policies for a
combined population that is twice of
theirs that's asinine so anyone who says
that nato forced the russians into this
is technically correct but they're also
stupid
there is no version of this there is no
off ramp that putin would accept because
he knows especially now
that if he fails that's the end and the
only thing that would be worse than not
launching the war would be launching it
and failing so he's not going to stop
what is the odds of nuclear war at this
point we know that they are armed uh we
know that the united states and
other nato allies have explicitly stated
they do not want to intervene
out of caution
and or appetite uh for participation but
cautioned to not trip kind of world war
three and nuclear war uh is that
avoidable or how do you think about the
the nuclear component or overlay on this
here's my concern um
ukraine is today is not the ukraine that
it was in 2013. if the russians had done
this in 2013 this war may well be over
already they didn't have a strong
national identity their military was
weak and there was a substantial
percentage of the population that was
overtly pro-russia that's not the case
anymore so now the russians are looking
to have to uh occupy a country that at
the start of the war had 45 million
people
that's going to take a couple million
troops and they only have a couple
million troops so from a conventional
point of view this is already the last
war that the russians will fight when
they move on to romania poland and the
rest it is a nuclear question because
that's the only way the russians can get
what they want so if
the russians can pacify ukraine and
moldova to their preference
they will then start explicitly
threatening nuclear attacks across nato
in order to get what they want in those
areas and they will not be afraid to use
nukes to do it
because from their point of view the end
is already nigh so better to go out
swinging and maybe possibly be able to
intimidate countries into giving them
what they want than not
and it's not as stupid as it sounds
because there are two pipelines that
take natural gas under the baltic sea
and under the black sea direct germany
and turkey and without germany and
turkey there is no nato function in this
area so we're getting very close to the
point that energies can be disrupted but
the germans and the turks can be offered
a deal that the russians can keep their
lights on and only their lights on but
only if they abandoned nato
i don't know how the germans and the
turks are going to respond to that but
that's probably the next chapter of this
which makes it absolutely beyond
critical that russia never sufficiently
pacify ukraine so that they feel they
can move on this is where from the west
point of view this has to end
and does that mean that if it is needed
your belief is that the united states
and nato should step in uh with boots on
the ground no flies no because that
would immediately trigger nukes no
this the ukrainians have to do the
fighting we can provide them with all
the equipment and intelligence and
targeting information that we can but if
we do if we have american soldiers in
ukraine the russians will know and then
it's a different sort of field if we put
fighter jets or start doing a no-fly
zone same thing the russians will feel
they have no choice but to escalate so
this has to remain conventional and it
has to remain in ukraine anything else
you are talking about mushroom clouds
yeah i tend to agree that the
de-escalation is incredibly important
here uh we've talked a lot about the
united states uh european countries um
and various allies uh we haven't spoken
as much about china and india china
seems to um
be taking more of an indifferent
approach maybe is the way i would
describe it uh where they're not
necessarily supportive of russia but
they're also not supportive of the us
and nato in terms of uh taking the
position that they're taking india also
seems to be a country that is uh heavily
reliant not only on uh the wheat and
fertilizer uh but also has much more of
an appetite to settle outside of uh the
sanctioned currencies uh to go ahead and
continue to
conduct bilateral trade how do you
evaluate uh kind of the the geopolitical
chess board right when i think of that
chessboard i think of you as as one of
the people who pays attention to it all
day long
those two chess pieces of china and
india seem uh to not necessarily be
aligned holistically with the us and
nato but maybe not also completely with
russia either what's your read here
well let's start with the indians
because it's a simpler situation
india never joined the global order they
were
definitely pro-soviet and even when the
soviet union died they continued to be
pro-soviet there there's a degree of um
ideological ketchup that the indians
have not yet done and they've barely
started actually
and so when they look at this situation
they see russia as soviet even though
they're not uh even though the russians
can't give them any of the money or most
of the weapons that in the past they
thought were viable
we're certainly seen on the battlefield
that russian weapons are not nearly as
useful
in a real war as we thought they were
so whenever you see
or
aside from that geographically the
indians are absolutely trapped in south
asia even if pakistan wasn't there
there's still deserts and mountains that
hem them in so india is incapable of
projecting economic and political power
into
europe in a way that would allow them to
establish an independent trade link they
can only trade with russia if the
europeans and the americans allow it and
i think in april that is going to stop
and the the indians will absolutely
[ __ ] but there's absolutely nothing
they can do about it also the damage is
done already in terms of the
agricultural situation so they're going
to be obsessing about that issue here
fairly soon
so that's india china
okay so
china joined the global order with mao
that was the whole point of the nixon
mouse summit
that we would bring the chinese into the
system if they would turn their back on
the soviets and it worked and that
contributed to the end of the cold war
without a shot being fired big victory
for both sides
both sides being the us and china not
the russians obviously
now the chinese have expanded by a
factor of 10 economically they see
themselves as a pure power to the
americans but they are unwilling to
admit that all of the growth that they
have had every little scrap of it is
because of the globalized system that
the u.s maintains
and when the russians fell under
sanction everything that the chinese
thought was true about their future was
laid bare as at best wishful thinking
and bad analysis so they are now looking
east to the united states and west to
the russians in a little bit of a panic
because they are being tied indirectly
to what's going on in ukraine and they
have now found out not only does the
west and specifically the united states
financial tools work very well they now
know they would work much better against
china than against russia because at its
core russia is a commodities exporter
most notably oil natural gas and food
china imports all those things
so if an equivalent sanctions regime was
done against the chinese you'd have 500
million dead chinese in less than a year
from starvation
and that assumes nothing else gets
folded into the situation
so the chinese are trying to wrestle
with the collapse of 50 years of
strategic planning and their core
ideology as being completely
non-functional
i'd say if you look at the rhetoric for
the last three weeks they're they're
doing a decent job of segwaying but you
don't you don't rip the mental roots out
of an entire system overnight makes
people just blink and then all of a
sudden be on the new scale
europeans have shown that maybe that is
a little bit more possible than i'm
saying here but the chinese have always
seen themselves as anti-american they've
always seen themselves as anti-western
anti-democracy and now they're realizing
that the mood
of the man in the white house determines
whether their country exists
they're not going to turn on a dime for
that
but we'll know
soon
i think this is another one of those
things that we've shaken out one way or
another by the end of april
uh oh one other thing
as as tight as the sanctions are and as
bigger as big as they're getting
they're nothing compared to the
corporate boycotts
almost every single company that left
russia was under no legal requirement to
do so they just didn't want to be
associated with the war and we're
talking about those esg social goody
two-shoes uh
mammoth companies like exxon and
halliburton who are now gone
and everyone else followed
so if that happened to china you know
that's all of their investment that
matters that's all of their technology
transfers that's all of their ant
markets
this system if it turned against china
would be far more damaging than anything
we've seen out of russia so far
yeah it's fascinating to kind of think
through the complexity here uh on the
geopolitical landscape uh we've got a
couple more minutes left and i want to
spend our time talking about bitcoin uh
my understanding is that uh you're not
nearly as excited about it maybe as i am
uh i think that's a safe bet it's one
way to uh to put it um
help me understand kind of like what's
your view on it and maybe actually what
would be interesting is like what are
the challenges that you think bitcoin
has that you probably have more
confidence or insurmountable than maybe
i or others have sure well i mean let's
start with the the
what works um blockchain digital
currency as i have no problem with that
i just see that as the next step in how
central banks manage their money supply
so it's not like i'm opposed to digital
writ large uh but bitcoin um anything
that is going to be a currency has to
have liquidity and bitcoin has no
mechanism for expanding what is
necessary to match market demands it is
based on how many people can crunch
however much data and then them getting
paid for it but that doesn't actually
generate anything of value that is not
in bitcoin already so there's no issuing
mechanism that works uh there's it's not
a method of exchange it's too volatile
there's no one that regulates its supply
there's no one that can make it access
this market or that market as legal
tender unless you want to be in what is
it is it el salvador one of the central
american countries yes i'd go that way
not working out great for them
uh
it's it's tulip mania without the tulips
i mean it doesn't it's not an asset
it's not a store value
it's not a method of exchange
and it's certainly not independent
because what we saw with the russian
sanctions is all the connections between
bitcoin and the real financial sector
got locked
and if you're going for bitcoin on a
libertarian basis i mean that should
just prove that there's any use to it at
all so that's kind of like the big three
from my point of view all right i want
to take each one of them uh individually
and sure
i don't come at this from um
the perspective of trying to convince
you differently but i think talking
through it actually is super educational
to both people who are critics and also
uh supporters of
the asset go for it so when i think of
uh a central bank right there's kind of
a framework i use which is uh most
people would say you need two things for
a central bank to be effective one is it
needs to be independent from political
uh influence et cetera you need to just
evaluate the monetary uh uh situation
and then two is that it needs to be
somewhat predictable so the more
surprises the central bank provides uh
the less effective it is or the less uh
uh people kind of trust it right so
predictability and i agree with you with
one exception if you are the global
currency that is not as necessary okay
fair very fair um and so when i think of
bitcoin one of the frameworks that i've
used to evaluate it is that it is a
automated central bank now automated is
this kind of word that can be used
across a bunch of different things but
it's just the fact that you i or nobody
else in the world can change the
monetary policy now maybe the monetary
policy is good or bad maybe it's
effective in a certain environment or
not effective but it just can't be
changed and the reason why in my opinion
that's important is because it has a
level of independence that it doesn't
matter if there's world war iii going on
kovid a recession the president is
tweeting about it or anything in between
it's just gonna stay the same and i
think that that at least on one kind of
analysis removes the uh
view that it is not independent so
when you put it that way it makes it
sound like digital gold and i would also
argue that gold is a horrible vehicle
for for store of value we've seen that
with the russians all of their gold is
in the country
they can't trade it yet it's worth
nothing to them now and and so when i
see bitcoin i mean yes it's there behind
the scenes but it's their connections to
the the real financial sector that allow
it to be exchanged and those can be
blocked by a central bank without even
needing an executive order so the degree
of vulnerability for the asset overall
just seems extreme to me i actually
think hearing you talk about this i
think you and i are going to agree on
something at the end but just bear with
me for a second okay so that's the
automated component of it the second is
the predictability and so this idea of a
programmatic monetary policy people
aren't sitting around waiting for the
press conference of are they gonna raise
interest rates 25 50 basis points or not
again you can argue whether good or bad
that it's fixed but it is fixed and
therefore when you have that
programmatic ability i know that it's
independent and i know that i have some
degree of certainty as to what's going
to happen in the future now your point i
think is the best critique of the
monetary policy which is that you do not
have anyone with the ability to expand
or contract the monetary supply or
manipulate the interest rate or kind of
the issuance rate in order to respond to
world events and so we think about pre
going off the gold standard it was
essentially the world had to cater to
the monetary policy and then we
basically broke from that and we said no
wait the monetary policy should cater to
the world right and that change
essentially created the last 50 plus
years of uh of economic uh boom now
when i think about
bitcoin
that like economic or monetary policy
argument is a big piece of the story but
it's not the only piece of the story and
i think your point about gold in russia
is a huge point that many people missed
here right it's their foreign reserves
and basically all of their assets that
were not held inside of russia are gone
now and so it brings you back to this
idea of like okay if that is true which
which it seems to be that is going to be
a new playbook that can be levied
against countries that fall out of favor
with uh the united states or nato allies
etc
then sovereignty becomes really
important and to your point gold sucks
it's heavy it's really hard to move
around who's going to accept it it's not
very divisible like all these challenges
with using gold
but if you could do that same exact
thing
with sovereignty in a digital world this
will remove all the problems because you
still need someone to accept it on the
other side but it does at least remove
what i would consider like the analog
friction it's not heavy it's easy to
move it you know with a click of a
button it can settle anywhere etc
and so
i don't know if bitcoin is the perfect
solution but it feels like whether you
evaluate from a monetary policy
standpoint around independence and uh
predictability or you evaluate it from a
sovereignty standpoint it's just better
than what we have
right how do you think about it you're
basically making the ev argument there
okay we rip out the old architecture and
put in an architecture that is designed
for this new asset then everything will
be fine unfortunately we have to
deal with life in between a and b and
the only people who can say that b is
better are the people who are theorizing
there's no there's no example of it and
we'd have to you know first break down
everything
so you're
so basically it's this idea of like hey
if we transition from a which is let's
call it the legacy or or
existing financial system to b which is
the new new right i'll put in air quotes
uh if it comes to fruition there's a
transition period that could be painful
inefficient
maybe not even possible et cetera that
that's so cool and you have to get every
central bank to surrender their
authority to
who
so
if we look around the world this is
where i think we're going to end up
agreeing uh is el salvador which i think
most people would argue uh pre
the bitcoin announcement most people
couldn't point to it on a map uh they
have
six and a half million people or so in
their population which is literally less
than you know new york city right as an
example to just see how small of a
country it is they've gone ahead and
what i
described as they've plugged their
country into the bitcoin standard now
what does that mean in practice they
bought some bitcoin
again millions of dollars not like
billions of dollars they have created an
atm network they created an app they
paid some of their citizens about 50 or
more of their citizens to buy bitcoin or
use bitcoin they paid them for it uh and
now they're setting up this uh
bitcoin-backed volcano bond et cetera so
they're like all in right and again
small country six and a half million
people
the part that is fascinating to me
is not so much
what is happening so far with bitcoin
as much as they're reporting that
tourism is up 30 year-over-year that gdp
has started to grow that actually they
have more than 50 percent of their
population who now hold bitcoin as a
savings technology etc
and so what i don't yet know because i
don't think we have enough time or or
data is
when somebody goes ahead and makes
bitcoin legal tender or adopts it which
now we're seeing in many other countries
so we just saw lugano switzerland
malaysia today just described that they
want to make bitcoin cryptocurrencies
legal tender there's numerous states in
the united states that more marketing
but but want to do it as well
is it actually the technology itself and
and what economic impact it creates or
is it more so become a flag in the
ground hey we want to be innovative we
want entrepreneurs we want to be
business friendly we want to be at the
forefront of this and that leads to the
positive impact of tourism gdp growth et
cetera like how do you think about
that
almost balance between the technology
itself versus the impact well let me
give you a scenario where bitcoin or
things like it might have a role in the
future okay uh the whole globalization
thread that has driven everything since
1945 that's what's breaking down right
now
and in in my second book absent
superpower i think one of the things i
said is it doesn't really matter where
the break happens it's going to cascade
so the russia ukraine war was one of the
specific examples like i had there was
one of the persian gulf there's one in
east asia
if you move away from the trade
environment that we have it's not that
the dollar standard goes away it
probably becomes more important because
the united states will be even more
emotionally disconnected from other
sections of the world and be more of an
impartial
arbiter and the dollar be more important
and take more market share
but if you break down into a series of
disconnected regional trading networks
not all of them have a country at its
core that i would consider an economic
power so when you're looking at certain
parts of the world they're going to lack
access to and influence over any sort of
federal reserve action having another
method of exchange that is not the
physical us dollar
has a role
you'll have to keep the electricity on
you'll have to keep the web working
and some of these places probably aren't
going to be able to manage that but
there are other ways to establish a
method of exchange in an environment
where the u.s just doesn't care about
half the planet
so here's a theory that i have uh i have
increasing
confidence that this is going to play
out um but i actually think that the us
dollar list uses an example and bitcoin
will rise in strength together
and one way to view it is there's a a
stable coin that is pegged to the
dollars an algorithmic stablecoin today
that recently they made the decision
rather than try to use exotic financial
mechanisms where people are arbitraging
risk to keep it at one dollar they
simply are going to get rid of that
system and move to a bitcoin backed
stablecoin so it's still a dollar pegged
asset
that is tradable and to your point has
stable value so you remove the
volatility concerns but the value
essentially replicates the gold standard
right it's paper claims on the gold now
you have a digital token valued at one
dollar that's pegged there and it has
some sort of underlying uh asset to it
i actually think that some of the weaker
currencies
that is the path in which
they essentially either adopt something
to drive value to their weak currency or
they will fall at the feet of the dollar
right there's consolidation around the
dollar strength and so we see these weak
currencies fail in the face of that
and so
one i guess just like what is your
reaction to that and two have you seen
anything that the weaker currencies are
doing to try to basically survive in the
face of a strengthening dollar and kind
of this world order that seems to be
shifting underneath it
there's um
there were
three strategies one of the strategies
used to be to find a regional poll like
the euro or the yuan to work with
that has becoming less and less popular
as people realize just how much the
chinese manipulate the currency and
especially in the in the aftermath of
this round of sanctions against the
russians even the euro is not seen as a
good role for that
so we're left with two others one is
amalgamation where you have a number of
countries that pool
their uh their financial have to make a
regional currency like the caribbean
dollar or
uh west africa had the west over and
frank i can't even honestly remember the
status of that right now this has
changed so much in the last two years
uh or option number three you just peg
it to the dollar you know and that's not
just belize that's de facto hong kong
and taiwan uh you you find ways to link
yourselves into the bond market so even
if the currencies do swing you have
enough exposure so you get brought along
for the swing and that's more or less
what the australians and the kiwis have
been doing for decades i see a lot more
of that moving forward
because the parts of the world that the
us is going to remain engaged in are the
western hemisphere plus southeast asia
and maybe maybe
maybe western europe
but if you're talking from about the
brits and the japanese and the us and
canada that's already four members of
the g7 and if you include the rest of
that kind of inner circle zone you're
still talking about two billion people
so either you can be associated with
that countries that have broadly
positive demographic growth and
consumption like growth moving forward
or you can tie yourself onto something
else where security is going to be a
bigger concern for you than the finance
and when that is how people are thinking
that security is more important than
finance i really have a hard time seeing
something like bitcoin uh coming in out
of the shadows
i think bitcoin is the most secure asset
in the world
right which is well because
hopefully this isn't the point you
wanted to end on because i'm not going
to agree on no no no no no no no no no
no i
didn't expect to uh just change your
mind on that here here is the the other
piece of it though is i think there's a
humanitarian argument that uh it's it
it's sad to talk about right because
we're watching it happen in real time
but there are millions of ukrainians who
are saying to themselves oh my god we're
being invaded i need to get out and
where i go uh i may not even have an
idea yet but i have to get to a border i
have to get out of my country and when
they do that they essentially look
around and they say what assets do i
have that i can take with me where is my
family and friends and how many of them
can i take with me and everything else
gets left behind businesses
wealth et cetera and we've seen this uh
unfortunately many times in history and
there's story after story after story
that you'll hear of you know we got on
the train with whatever was in our bag
and that's basically where we went to
the
new home and survived from there
there is this element of if the world
order breaks down and globalization
breaks down to some degree we see more
chaos more uncertainty even potentially
more violent conflict the place where
you want to have your wealth
is actually in a digital asset that you
can take with you that can't be
confiscated that can't be seized that
you can carry as much you carry billions
and billions of dollars with you
and so what i've been thinking about is
there's a trade-off no asset no market
no anything is perfect and so for
example if you're in ukraine do you care
that an asset swings 10 a day if the
opposite or kind of opportunity is
basically leave it behind
right
and in that situation you probably say
hey look i'll take the 10 swings as long
as i can get it out yeah just keep in
mind that from a government's point of
view the same things that make that give
that a positive spin and make that
useful
are
oh oh so attractive to organize crime
yeah i i i think that that is a fair
concern what
you can't have one without the other and
if governments are faced with that
situation i can tell you how all of them
are going to come down they're trying
right now uh i i think the no they're
not they're really not yet because
because the liquidity is the liquidity
of bitcoin is not enough to attract
organized crime at the moment as soon as
if that were to change
then oc would go into it very big and
governments would come down on in a very
very big and painful way i
i think that the law enforcement cia and
uh various governments they love bitcoin
they love it because it's an open
transparent ledger and if you're an
idiot and you use bitcoin to conduct
crimes i think they have confidence that
they'll be able to figure it out like
would you rather conduct the crime with
physical cash or with you know kind of
your hands on a keyboard what a law
enforcement agent one time told me uh at
the federal level he said you know if
somebody commits a crime we want their
hands on a keyboard like drastically
increases the odds that we catch them
and i always think about that as in
terms of bitcoin where
if you commit a crime using an open
immutable ledger that they can analyze
forever
they're probably going to catch you
you know i just um
from what i know about how the mexican
cartels work they are more than savvy
enough to make that work for them
the i'm not messing with the cartels
yeah exactly
yeah it's like it's just the the way
that you can
shove things through a system like that
and and bring in intermediaries who
might not even know it just seems robust
i i think that that's uh uh a fair view
to take given the current information uh
before i let you go uh you have your
book coming out in june uh the end of
the world is just the beginning mapping
the collapse of globalization give us
kind of a quick 30-second 60-second uh
overview as to why uh why people should
go get it sure so the previous books
were all about the rise and fall of
nations and you know there's a lot on
the russian ukraine wars and all three
of them
but the new book is looking at it from
the back side of a de-globalized world
what happens when the connections that
make everything work stop
what are all the various economic
structures from finance to agriculture
to manufacturing how do they break down
and how do they reform on the other side
i i think that this is like uh maybe the
book to go read this summer
may be pretty important so anyone who uh
who has not read any of peter's books i
highly suggest that they're they're very
well written but also uh they really
just make you think uh everything from
uh
disunited nations uh etc so uh the end
of the world is just the beginning
mapping the collapse of globalization
it's available for pre-order uh amazon
everywhere uh which by the way i also uh
my brothers will find this uh funny the
books i even out here it's already
number one bestseller
really
it is the number one bestseller in
middle eastern politics is
one of many places yeah amazon has so
many categories that everyone is the
best seller okay i got really excited
there for a second
after your appearance here today will be
the number one bestseller in all of
amazon if that happens then you know who
to credit yeah all right where can we
buy us some bitcoin
[Laughter]
where can we send people to find you on
the internet sure so the website is
zion.com
z-e-i-h-a-n dot com uh there's a
newsletter you can sign up that is free
that is always free my twitter handle is
at peter zion and i am an equal
opportunity bubble popper so just be
prepared
awesome well thank peter so much this is
uh fantastic i could literally talk to
you for hours about this stuff you've
been uh all over this and uh gave us a
great breakdown today so we'll have to
do it again in the future
all right sounds great all right thank
you thanks peter
take care